i am sad because i'm an english major
and as an english major you have to read
[Music]
i'm not the fastest reader nor am i the
slowest reader
that information is supposed to be
descriptive and not totally vague
and my dilemma and my sadness is that
i'm starting
school next week college i'm not i'm not
in high school
this is my last hurrah my last week
where i can just really read whatever
the hell i want
i need i need to set goals it's time for
me to set some real reading goals
and i feel like if i pronounce it into
the void of the internet then i'm
somehow held to some kind of commitment
psychologically claim that i'm going to
read these books
this fall this quarter in no particular
order
most definitely not all of them but i
have some options
i love halloween i love to fall and i
love
ray bradberry fun fact me and ray
bradbury share the same
birthday come on that's a good birthday
brad berry's been like a childhood hero
of mine and
huge inspiration to me over the blah
blah blah anyways i haven't read
a lot of his his writing uh i've read
short stories in fahrenheit 451 but i
haven't read
something wicked this way comes oh my
god i was just looking recently i have
this book
in three different copies i do not know
why
i figured i better read it all i know
about this is that there's a carnival
there's a a creepy guy who who wanders
into town
i do know spoilers about the ending why
do i i feel like i
i know the ending to every book i read i
don't know why i'm going to
really read this because i love the way
bradbury writes
i'm excited for that uh let me talk
about what i'm currently reading william
faulkner's book the mansion i'm going to
do a review of
the snopes trilogy this is the third in
a trilogy so far
it's pretty damn good afterwards
i'm going to read oathbringer uh
i'm gonna i'm gonna do it i have the
hardcover the other ones i read in the
mass market paperbacks really feels like
a long book now that it's
it's like weighs like a [ __ ] ton of
bricks more books i want to read
i've been craving some hard sci-fi who
better to go with than arthur c clarke
rendezvous with rama i've heard that the
sequels are [ __ ]
don't know if that's real or true or
whatever i know that he co-wrote them
this one is is supposedly a sci-fi
classic from the
70s i'm a huge fan of uh the
space odyssey series besides rendezvous
with rama i'll read
imperial earth which i don't know
anything about but
i love that cover i mean pov you're
standing
on a hole more
science fiction these are just options
you know i'm not i'm not trying to
hold myself accountable to read all of
the foundation trilogy but
this is on the plate for for the fall
apple tv or amazon or netflix or whoever
the [ __ ] is doing some
cool new adaptation of the foundation
trilogy and people are going to want to
hear what i have to say about the
foundation trilogy right
gosh look at look at this this trilogy
this is when avon
just you know did books i think the
covers are so
pretty and weird weird weird covers i
mean i wish
i wish we had some weirder covers of
books honestly these days like
the new cover of doon i'm not a huge fan
of
just because it's it's really not weird
enough i mean i miss when science
fiction had
just just bat [ __ ] crazy covers or just
really suggestive looking covers i
missed that era of
book publishing you know the era that i
never lived through
nostalgia for a time that never existed
i've been hearing about uh
guy gavriel kay and about how he's a
great
fantasy writer who writes you know with
really beautiful vivid
prose i found this copy of a song for
arbonne
our bone i don't know how to pronounce
that i saw daniel green's
video about tagana i just was like man i
really need to read
these books i also saw brandon sanderson
hyping up
guy gavriel kay in his lecture series
which everyone should watch
also i would like to read some stuff
that is not fantasy
for nickel boys by colson whitehead
incredible writer and
i don't really know what it's about but
i've heard that it's very depressing
i will i will read this when i'm ready
to
feel sad i suppose which let's be real
is all the time
all the time i want to feel sad that's
it for now wait
i'm forgetting i can't go through the
fall without reading a stephen king book
i'm going to read either it the stand
i don't know yet which i'll do maybe it
just because i have a really cool
copy of it i don't know what should i
read the suggestions are welcome
you know suggest away go ahead i'll
listen to what you have to say
i will actually and another
god i'm really like this i'm really like
packing my
list of books i need to read but i'm i'm
going to say it
i don't care that you broke your elbow
i'm putting on my fall tbr
account of monte cristo i've actually
heard that it's
uh pretty easy to get through it's a
pretty fast read unfortunately i need to
buy
a new translation of the the whole book
because i have over the years i've
gotten multiple copies of the count of
monte cristo apparently there was some
kind of
anonymous translation of the count of
monte cristo in the 1800s that got rid
of a lot of the
naughty bits not very faithful to the
actual
uh french original apparently the
definitive one uh english translation of
the counter minor crystal you have to
read
is by robin buss that's the
definitive way to read it and now i have
to buy another copy of a book
i will be doing weekly videos every week
that's what weekly means
tune in if you uh like and subscribe to
this video
you will be rewarded i won't say how
that
is in god's hands i should not be saying
that thanks for watching
bye
go ahead it's fine i'm the video is done
it's really it's okay i i the video is
done you can just go ahead and
leave
[Music]
i'm gonna have to ask you to leave